please be with you how you guys doing
have a special treat I have UFC fighter
Hector Lombard and he's going to be with
us God willing in the future a couple
points that we were talking about Todd
is very interesting one was you said
some very brilliant word you talk he's
talked about I hate the word hey what
can you share that darkness how
important it is not to hate very
important not to hate why because once
you hate you don't learn once you hate
you separate yourself from the truth and
you know with a you know religion with a
specifically hitting people we were
talking exactly when you know whether
yes whether you people sports whatever
once once you hate used to print from
the truth once you hate you separate
people we should be you know especially
as athletes you know United people
bringing because you travel you transfer
people from although it's likely i
believe i believe like young love and
embrace each other no hate each other
that's beautiful we're going to be
talking about more stuff like this god
willing and one more thing was you know
nutrition that's the key to help eating
healthy good food real food today fifty
percent of people living today will have
cancer here right here where the most
sickest nation we spend the most on
health care and i was just amazed you
were telling me where you're from it's
almost like cancers almost non-existent
it's like tell us a little nothing um
you know everybody knows they're come
from Cuba born in Cuba and I remember
when I was a kid they was I never heard
about diseases and stuff of that I was
like so after all you know after came to
your countries like Australia and
America you know I started you know
hearing about the concert and stuff i
doubt i was like what the hell is that
and
and everything is you know with the
processed food and I believe everything
is involved with the food is you know
he's the one you know you have to blame
in that area and you guys over there
you're eating in QA real food you Tom
otro fruit from the tree SI Claire's no
McDonald's Burger King none of these
plate their own burger king no quarter
no processed food she's real food etc
and you got real help you real healthy
yeah so these are the kind of things I
don't want to give it away we're gonna
be talking about God one the next time
what happen again you bay all right
thank you guys piece solid